j'ai écrit ce livre parce que quand
j'étais moi-même un peu
désorienté j'avais eu la chance de lire
le livre de mon arrière-grand-père qui
était médecin aussi qui était parisien
il y a de tout dans la famille
et
c'était extrêmement instructif de voir
toutes les étapes par lequel il était
passé les difficultés dans lequel il
passait ça s'appelait du quartier à
l'Académie donc il parlait du moment où
l'été étudiant et donc je trouvais que
pour
expliquer ou raconter comment les choses
se passent et comment il faut pas se
laisser émouvoir ni impressionné quand
on croit qu'on fait les choses
correctement il faut avoir une armature
si vous voulez et moi bien sûr je suis
très reconnaissant à ma famille de
m'avoir donné une armature
qui permet de supporter tout ça avec la
plus grande indifférence alors vous avez
dit que là vous avez dit un instant vous
avez dit j'ai relu le livre de mon
grand-père parce que c'est vrai que
j'étais j'avais dit moi j'étais un petit
peu voilà je vous posais des questions
avec tout ce qui se passait tout ça vous
aviez besoin vous étiez est-ce que vous
étiez vous avez vécu un moment de moins
bien c'était vraiment où tout ce qui
s'est édition où est-ce que ça va ça
vous a vraiment affecté ou pas non
absolument pas je moi le j'ai
vécu ma scolarité de Madame épouvantable
parce que je m'ennuyais à trois je me
faisais virer partout j'étais un très
mauvais élève alors justement déjà vous
dites dès votre enfant sont remarque une
chose vous avez déjà une tendance à être
irrévérencieux vous étiez pas fan de
l'autorité
c'était pas pour vous c'est pas pour moi
ça va tout jeune âge vous dites tu ne
comprenais pas pourquoi les autres
n'osaient pas faire des choses qui de
mon point de vue sembler parfaitement
naturel comme la résistance à l'autorité
et le refus de l'injustice ainsi à
maison Lafitte alors que j'avais 7 ou 8
ans j'ai demandé un jour aller aux
toilettes comme Raymond parce qu'une
envie pressante peser sur ma vessie
face au refus catégorique de
l'instituteur j'ai ouvert ma braguette
au milieu de la classe et uriner par
terre pour me soulager donc voilà
professeur Raoul
c'est
important de cette anecdote dans le
livre oui et puis encore une fois moi je
l'ai trouvé avant de trouver mon
équilibre j'ai honte de dire ça moi j'ai
trouvé l'équilibre à partir du moment où
j'ai travaillé comme une mule et que
donc je n'ai plus été oisif et que j'ai
plus de questions j'étais content
japonais j'apprenais à partir de moment
où je découvre ça j'ai plus que
m'arrêter parce que et j'ai arrêté de
m'ennuyer et de faire des bêtises parce
que j'étais content de de m'occuper de
d'apprendre des choses j'ai l'impression
de pas perdre mon temps en tout cas pour
tous les jeunes qui nous regardent ça
donne espoir le professeur a oui était
nul à l'école pendant longtemps ça nous
fait du bien on se dit bon voilà on va
pouvoir peut-être faire quelque chose un
jour on découvre aussi chez vous un réel
mal-être dans le livre jeune au point
que vous avez été jusqu'à faire une
fausse tentative de suicide parce que
vous racontez
vous dites l'année de ma fausse
tentative de suicide inconsciemment
destiné à l'air t'aimer parents sur mon
mal-être et sur le calvaire que je
vivais au quotidien sur les bancs du
collège pourquoi vous qu'est-ce qui se
passait
je trouve que cette tendance de faire
marcher tout le monde au même pas été
c'est très difficile beaucoup de gens de
mon époque moi je rond des souvenirs
extrêmement désagréable moi j'ai souvenu
extraordablement désagréable du lycée je
pensais qu'à une chose c'est que ce soit
fini ou avant d'aller c'est ce que j'ai
fait moi j'ai pas fait de première ni de
terminale je passais mon bac en candidat
libre tellement je m'ennuyais je voulais
qu'une chose c'est m'en aller lui c'est
vous vous en diriez parce que c'était
franchement vous trouvez que c'était
trop simple
vous aviez des potes au lycée tout ça
oui oui mais c'est à dire le lycée les
questions qu'on nous traiter ou la
vitesse à laquelle les choses se
passaient n'étaient pas intéressantes je
m'ennuyais et c'est terrible ennuie si
tu ne d'ailleurs pour lequel j'ai très
peu participé à des
à des rencontres ministérielles ou parce
que rester trois heures à écouter les
bêtises si vous voulez parce que chacun
se sera obligé de dire quelque chose
d'intelligent qu'il l'est pas si vous
voulez je peux pas le supporter et de
regarder je préfère rester chez moi
voilà
et donc je m'ennuyais mais profondément
voilà et donc l'ennui c'était terrible
pour moi mais j'ai mis longtemps avant
de me rendre compte quand je me suis
rendu compte qu'en réalité la réponse
était de de travailler et d'apprendre
d'apprendre à ce qu'on appelle la
médecine c'était pas votre grande
passion au départ
non mais c'est compliqué c'est je
j'avais 16 ans 68 donc c'est une époque
très particulière dans lequel dans
lequel on considérait que c'était un
péché mortel de faire le même métier que
son père déjà c'est comme ça c'était
truc
donc en plus on disait tous les études
ça sert à rien et en plus moi mon
expérience du lycée c'était que vraiment
c'était ennuyeux et donc tout ça amené
et puis on avait un mythe breton de
devenir marin deux de mes frères sont
devenus ma main d'ailleurs hein la
marine à voile avec la chose qui vous
tenait à cœur et puis voilà et puis au
bout d'un moment je me suis rendu compte
que j'aurais fait un marin médiocre que
faire quelque chose dans le domaine dans
lequel je me sentirai pas médiocre si
grand public vous a découvert
majoritairement en 2020 avec la pandémie
de covid-19 vous étiez déjà un véritable
pont de la médecine bien avant parce
qu'il faut savoir la consécration pour
vous ça a été notamment quand vous avez
reçu la Légion d'honneur pour vous c'est
une véritable continuité familiale vous
dites dans ma famille cette famille de
héros j'ai trouvé ma place j'ai été très
fière quand je suis devenu officier de
la Légion d'Honneur j'étais la quatrième
génération d'officiers de la Légion
d'Honneur quand Napoléon l'a créé il
disait qu’après deux ou trois
générations le titre était
définitivement acquis à la famille ce
qui correspond à un titre de noblesse ça
c'est c'est votre plus grande fierté
en tout cas
si vous voulez comme tout le monde
encore une fois j'ai l'âge que j'ai je
fais partie d'une génération qui est ce
qu'elle était on avait un profond métri
pour les médailles tout ça c'est des
bêtises tout ça ne compte pas mais il se
trouve que j'avais beaucoup beaucoup
investi dans les affaires collectifs
puisque j'étais devenu un très jeune
président de l'université pour dans des
circonstances épouvantables
l'Universités épouvantable que j'ai dû
redresser j'ai dû
m'y investir à un point très très fort
et j'ai fait à l'âge de 42 ans je fais
un petit infarctus
c'était le le 8 mai 95 et le même 8 mai
95 j'ai été nommé dans l'ordre du mérite
et donc j'ai commencé à trouver que les
médailles finalement c'était pas mal
parce qu'en même temps quelqu'un s'était
rendu compte
c'était ma première médaille que
finalement j'avais beaucoup donné pour
essayer de faire quelque chose
au service objectifs en fait oui ça me
plaisait et puis du coup après si vous
voulez c'est ça paraît stupide mais
c'est un peu finalement traduit ce livre
je me suis rendu compte que c'est
incroyable que j'ai fait exactement ce
que mon père folie je fasse sans jamais
m'en être rendu quand je m'en suis rendu
compte à 44 ou 45 ans enfin c'est très
c'est terrible d'être aussi aveugle
alors
c'est gênant dans votre lit vous
racontez beaucoup beaucoup de choses
vous êtes revenu vous revenez longuement
bien sûr et c'est ce que vous attendez
aussi 20h50 en direct avec le professeur
Raoul sur TPMP vous revenez longuement
bien sûr sur cette pandémie qui vous a
rendu célèbre dans le monde entier tout
d'abord vous étiez obligé de revenir sur
un point primordial pour vous la
chloroquine et toutes les polémiques au
sujet de ce traitement que vous
préconisiez et pour vous c'est très
clair vous aviez raison depuis le départ
vous dites car au-delà de la
satisfaction égoïste que nous pourrions
éprouver avec la démonstration que nous
avons bel et bien raison nous aurons
toujours le regret d'avoir échoué à
convaincre au bon moment au détriment
des malades que le covid a durement
affecté
hydroxychloroquine ça soigne donc pour
vous le covid c'est ce que vous dites là
on est en train les difficultés à passer
le message je reviens donc mais il se
trouve que c'est très bien d'ailleurs
vous voyez comme j'ai souffert de ça pas
du tout parce que chaque obstacle si
vous voulez oblige à réfléchir et à
tester ça sa propre capacité à répondre
aux difficultés donc
si on arrive à les résoudre on est on a
l'estime de soi fallait content d'avoir
réussi à me passer d'obstacle là et donc
vous savez peut-être mais il y a une
télévision qui a sorti des documents
donc je sais pas d'où il sortait et
disons que nos résultats étaient faux
c'est pas vrai c'est bien donc ça nous a
obligé on a fait venir un huissier pour
faire saisir sur nos ordinateurs les
résultats que nous avions reçu de façon
à dire attendez on peut pas raconter
tout le temps n'importe quoi et du coup
on a fait quelque chose qui est quelque
chose qui a été fait pour la première
fois qui est on a traité un peu plus de
30 000 personnes allez je suis d'accord
aussi bien en ambulatoire en hôpital de
jour que en hospitalier ou il y en a un
peu plus de 5000 hospitalisés et on a
décidé d'avoir une
une approche et une définition de ce
travail qui soit entièrement neutre
c'est à dire qu'on ne puisse pas qu'ils
ne puisse pas être rendu subjectif par
notre analyse donc on a pris 100% on a
fait contrôler par un huissier parce
qu'on est accusé de mentir d'inventer
les malades vous avez tout fait dans les
règles pour montrer que
valider par un huissier officiellement
pour saisir tous les malades
deuxièmement tout leur traitement c'est
directement la Pharmacie centrale des
hôpitaux c'est pas nous on les a mis en
face et pour évaluer l'efficacité
thérapeutique on a regardé les morceaux
sur l'Insee c'est pas nous qui avons
défini écrit d'accord et quand on
regarde comme ça chez les patients
hospitalisés on sauve 45% des gens avec
de l'hydroxyrocking chez les patients
qui sont en traitement précoce on sauve
70% ce qui veut dire qu'on estime que
avec le traitement pour
l'hydroxycloquine on a sauvé entre 500
et 1000 personnes si vous en faites une
extrapolation au niveau du pays je sais
pas si vous voyez pourquoi ça suscite
des des des réactions aussi violentes
parce que si j'ai raison ça veut dire
qu'il y a plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui auraient pu être sauvées
quand même parce que ça a été très
contesté forcément voilà et donc c'est
vrai que vous avez aujourd'hui avec du
recul vous êtes sûr de votre coup sur
les sur l'hydroxyde avec absolument
encore une fois on a déjà déposé ça on a
déposé le papier et on a déposé pour
qu'elle soit publique ce que personne ne
fait hein il y a pas une des études qui
a été publiée dans lequel les données
soient entièrement disponibles pour tout
le monde donc je pense qu'on va faire un
pas vous voyez encore aux États-Unis
jusqu'à un passé récent et c'était le
cas y compris pour Fighter pour le
vaccin les les laboratoires avaient le
droit de protéger de manière
confidentielle les résultats de leurs
études pendant 10 ans et nous ce qu'on
dit c'est dès que vous publiez votre
étude les données doivent être
immédiatement disponible pour que tout
le monde puisse aller les regarder et
exhaustive alors plus globalement vous
en voulez au lobby pharmaceutique vous
les défoncer dans le livre la corruption
dans ce milieu vous le dites n'est pas
un fantasme c'est très ce passage les
études peuvent être biaisées en fonction
des pays où elles sont conduites des
stratégies thérapeutiques qui sont qui
ont été adoptées et des intérêts
financiers des grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui alimentent le marché
et le fait de dire de le dire pour
l'avoir moi-même constater ce n'est pas
de mon point de vue du complotisme mais
du réalisme ce sont des faits pas des
hypothèses la corruption est endémique
pas fantasmagorique avec des des
passages comme ça il y a de plus en plus
de gens qui disent quand ils présentent
le professeur Raoul moi j'ai même vu
j'ai même vu des articles disaient oui
TPMP reçoit même des des complotistes
dont le professeur Raoul quand on vous
dit vous êtes un compotiste surtout
quand vous écrivez des choses comme ça
ça doit vous agacer quand même non non
je m'en fiche complètement si vous
voulez un exemple que j'ai donné
récemment parce que ça m'intéresse les
deux points dire que l'industrie
pharmaceutique et de la corruption c'est
une surprise pour les gens c'est parce
que les gens s'intéressent rien
globalement à peu près toutes les
grandes industries ont été condamnées à
plusieurs
d'accord pour fraude aux États-Unis en
France on les condamne pas mais aux
États-Unis donc un de ceux qui a payé le
plus c'est pour l'histoire du Geox 60
000 morts personne en prison mais quand
même 5 milliards
ne pas savoir que l'industrie c'est
juste de l'ignorance l'histoire de
l'OxyContin l'OxyContin c'est pas moi
qui ça c'est Obama considéré que ça
faisait 100 000 morts par an
l'occidental conseiller par McKinsey
c'est en soi plusieurs milliards
maintenant ils sont entièrement ruinés
parce qu'ils faisaient croire que
l'OxyContin qui est un dérivé la
morphine n'était pas addictif ce qui est
quand même il faut un culot terrible
pour arriver à vendre ça et ça a été
publié dans lui un grand journal of
meeting ça a été publié dans le landset
tout ça le vieux que ça a été publié
ça à l'époque où
moi je parlais pas du vieux parce que
c'est pas un antibiotique c'est pas un
anti affectueux mais vous savez il y a
un le rédacteur en chef du landset qui a
écrit qu'ils étaient complètement
corrompus que leur financement majeur
est celui de l'industrie pharmaceutique
dans les quatre derniers rédacteurs en
chef du New England of meeting il y en a
trois qui ont écrit un livre en disant
écoutez on ne peut plus faire de
recherche normale actuellement parce que
le poids relatif le coût relatif et la
valeur relative de de la de l'industrie
pharmaceutique est trop importante ce
qui est d'ailleurs c'est pas étonnant ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est déjà
mais qu'une industrie qui fait de
l'argent c'est pas il faut pas être plus
bienveillant avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique avec celle des gens qui
vendent du papier du pétrole ou
n'importe quoi la différence c'est qu'on
ne les traite pas de la même manière
est-ce que vous trouvez raisonnable de
penser qu'en Europe on puisse n'avoir
aucune trace de négociation d'un truc
qui a coûté 41 milliards de dollars il y
a une trace de la négociation et si oui
le rêve des civil a une signature de de
Ursula d'un milliard de dollars la
veille du jour où l'OMS disait sa serva
Ryan et c'était les mêmes experts qui
étaient de donc après mon Dieu aussi si
vous trouvez que ces bananes il y a
aucun domaine dans lequel on passe des
contrats de cette manière là donc il
faut traiter l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est utile mais il faut le traiter les
gens qui dirigent qui font c'est de
l'argent c'est donc il faut le traiter
comme une industrie ou comme comme des
marchands ordinaires vous savez qu'ils
sont pas traités voilà ils sont traités
d'une façon qui est pas pour vous qui
est qui est pas logique parce que ils
sont pas traités comme les autres
trouvez qu'on oublie que lundi industrie
pharmaceutique c'est une entreprise dans
votre tête en tout cas c'est c'est ce
que l'on voit encore une fois vous vous
imaginez un autre domaine mais bien sûr
l'Europe a jamais fait à chaque pareil
41 milliards de dollars c'est
hallucinant vous imaginez qu'il y a un
autre domaine dans lequel on puisse dire
écouter on peut pas vous dire pourquoi
on a pris ça mais la santé parce que la
santé les on se dit voilà c'est le voilà
c'est donc pour ça il y a aucune
transparence il y a aucune trace il y a
rien mais c'est c'est inouïe qu'on
accepte ça alors au sujet des vaccins
alors que vous n'avez jamais été un
antivax vous continuez à dire qu'on a
été trop loin trop fort trop vite c'est
donc avec un certain effarement que j'ai
vu c'est digue CD sous la pression du
covid et de tous ceux qui ont été
responsables avaient peur qu'on vienne
un jour ou l'autre le reprocher de
n'avoir rien fait ou pas assez ou trop
tardivement pourtant nous c'est à dire
les infectiologues savions dès le départ
que vacciné absolument toute la
population n'empêcherait pas la
transmission du virus sur le vaccin on
s'est précipités
si vous voulez
pour analyser correctement l'efficacité
et le la dangerosité d'un vaccin c'est
théoriquement impossible de le faire en
moins de 3 ans là ça s'est passé en
trois mois donc le la contagiosité n'a
jamais été testé on a testé que les gens
qui étaient malades pas les gens qui
étaient porteurs jamais d'accord pour
pour et donc et en plus toutes les
populations n'ont pas pu être testées en
trois mois c'est-à-dire qu'on sait pas
on n'a pas testé les enfants on n'a pas
testé femme enceintes et donc si vous
voulez on est arrivé dans cette
situation d'affolement général dans
lequel on pouvait pas soigner les gens
on pouvait plus rien faire tout le monde
allait mourir je vous rappelle
simplement la moitié des gens qui sont
morts et plus de 85 ans quand même et
qu'avant 50 ans il y avait pas de mort
quand même donc on a vendu sur l'espèce
de catastrophe éminente pour lequel il y
avait aucune solution et pour lequel il
fallait avoir tout de suite une solution
et généraliser nous on a été le premier
endroit à vacciner à Marseille bien
entendu on a vacciné quand les gens
demandaient pas avec les gens de force
vous pouvez pas savoir les gens étaient
tellement affolés que les gens pleurer
de joie on les vaccine ça leur c'est
inouïe ce que la demande qui avait été
suscité était arrivé à un point
absolument incroyable et donc
toutes les barrières qui permettent de
prendre le temps d'évaluer quel est le
risque et qu'elle bénéfice ont été
rompus les digues ont été rompus pour
pouvoir tout de suite répondre à ce
besoin à cet affolement qu'il y avait à
trouver une réponse immédiate vous en a
voulu de dire des choses comme ça
on a voulu vous en a voulu parce que
vous êtes devenu persona dans le gratin
parce que c'est c'était vraiment c'est
ce qui se passait en sécurité on fait ce
Raoul je vous le dis même moi même
partout on voulait le voir partout c'est
à dire que le professeur a voulait pas
faire beaucoup d'émission il est il
accepté certaines émissions il a accepté
Laurence Ferrari ils accepté de faire
des émissions avec nous mais tout le
monde le voulait il choisissez les
missions qui voulaient faire et c'est
vrai que après nous je vous dis je vois
souvent il invite le professeur Raoul
oui on invite le professeur Raoul sachez
qu'on continuera à inviter le professeur
Raoul voilà parce que j'ai vu des
journalistes qui disent ils invitent le
professeur à ou préfère inviter le
professeur Raoul qui a des choses
intéressantes à nous dire plutôt que des
grades papier qui disent des conneries
sur des articles donc je vous le dis
donc arrêtez de bien serrer les Luna
invite le professeur à ou je continuerai
à l'inviter le professeur Raoul et il
viendra continuer ici voilà donc je vous
le dis donc arrêtez de mettre ça c'est
insupportable voilà comme ça ça s'est
dit ça va aussi vous vous mettez vous
mettez dans la gueule des collègues dans
le dans le livre
c'est vrai sur les collègues vous y
allez aussi vous faites plaisir sur
nombreux collègues vous dites pendant
que beaucoup collègue faisait la
politique sur les plateaux de télévision
à Paris nous avons continué à faire de
la science à Marseille
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas nul ça je
vais le reprendre comment mais je vais
le reprendre pour les gars non non c'est
vrai hein franchement c'est ils ont
voulu vous en voulez un certain
collègues parce que quand vous avez été
mis à l'écart de vos fonctions c'est
vrai que on a on a senti vraiment qui
avait je sais pas il y avait il y avait
on a demandé on a demandé votre tête on
a l'impression vraiment qu'on a demandé
votre tête qu'on s'est dit le professeur
à ou prend trop de place il est trop
populaire il faut le casser c'est ce que
vous avez senti
je pense que si vous voulez
je veux pas surestimer mon rôle je pense
que si vous voulez un moment il y a des
gens qui qui symbolise ou qui incarne
un problème en soi donc je je pense que
j'ai été ça dans l'occasion si vous
regardez il y a un truc qui est très
mais il y a eu des choses très très
positives dedans moi j'ai fait découvrir
à beaucoup de journalistes entre autres
des sites pour aller voir les données
réelles et arrêter simplement de
discuter avec des gens qui leur donnait
leur opinion il y en avait un qui était
facile que tout le monde peut regarder
que ça s'appelle euro Ford box qui est
l'industrie pharmaceutique est obligé de
déclarer l'argent qu'elle donne aux
praticiens au médecin en France ça veut
pas dire elle peut leur donner ailleurs
parce que il y a pas toujours triché
quand même passé par dessus d'ailleurs
on peut leur donner en Angleterre ou en
Espagne et le déclareront pas où on peut
leur payer un congrès aux États-Unis et
pas le déclar mais si vous regardez ça
vous savez les choses étaient assez
simples dans les infections là les qui
n'avait pas pour des raisons qui étaient
des raisons de choix qui n'avaient pas
de relation qui n'avait pas reçu
d'argent dans les six dernières années
par l'industrie pharmaceutique c'était
les gens de l'iaq et Péronne je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire c'est donc quand on
a dit vous savez il y a des billets il y
a des conflits d'intérêts qui me sont
absolument pas déclarés il y a des gens
qui touchent à la fois de l'argent moi
le premier c'est pour ça que ça a
commencé très vite dès que j'ai commencé
par parler de la cloquine j'ai reçu des
coups de téléphone anonyme dans le
cheminant qui sont plus anonymes c'est
pour faire raffiner de Nantes qui
m'appelait
identifié grâce à la police il a été
condamné on peut le dire et c'est lui le
téléphone la nuit à minuit et donc pour
me menacer donc le le c'est celui qui
était le numéro 1 de tous les
financements il avait reçu 600000 euros
de l'industrie pharmaceutique les 6
dernières années c'est le numéro 1 après
vous pouvez toujours dire vous êtes
complotiste c'est possible qu'il y a un
lien ou c'est faut-il que soit une
coïncidence soyez mais c'est c'est ça
amène à réfléchir sur le fait est-ce que
c'est vraiment de la recherche médicale
de fournir des malades à des programmes
écrits par l'industrie pharmaceutique
dont les données ne sont analysées que
par l'industrie pharmaceutique qui fait
écrire ça parce qu'on appelle les
gaufres tracteurs d'ailleurs des
écrivains professionnels et qui sont
acceptés à l'avance par les plus grands
journaux parce qu'on sait que ça va
rapporter un argent fou aux journaux
même qu'il est publique donc pour vous
c'est un gros complot
c'est pas du tout c'est une évolution de
la société auquel nous ne sommes pas
préparés il y a plusieurs éléments
les gens n'ont pas l'habitude qu'une
molécule puisse servir à plus d'une
chose c'est un point et donc les seuls
qui vraiment est travaillé là-dessus
nous on a un peu travaillé dessus mais
c'est beaucoup les Chinois si vous
voulez ils ont ils ont pris toutes les
molécules qui sont considérées comme non
toxiques par la FDA c'est l'équivalent
de l'entrée NSM pour les tester sur le
covid ils ont trouvé 20 molécules qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir avec les
antiviraux qui sont efficaces donc des
antidépresseurs dont un antipar me
souviens après on s'est rendu compte que
les gens qui avaient les parkingsson
faisaient les formes moins graves ou pas
de covid et en réalité c'est parce que
un des médicaments qu'on donne pour la
maladie de Parkinson est un médicament
qui a une activité contre le virus si on
teste l'activité sur le il y a des
neuroleptiques qui ont une activité sur
le views donc l'idée que chaque molécule
a une activité unique qui est juste
celle pourquoi on la testait au départ
c'est un fantasme c'est pas vrai donc
celle dont on sait au départ qu'elles ne
sont pas toxiques parce qu'on les
utilise depuis 20 30 40 ans qui ne coûte
pas cher parce que comme elles ont plus
de 20 ans elles sont plus protégées par
des brevets c'est celle qui devrait en
priorité nous intéresser par exemple
on a regardé on a retrouvé d'ailleurs
des travaux pour ça quand on dit c'est
il y a une très grande résistance des
bactéries aux antibiotiques nous on a
testé effectivement les 2500 molécules
qui qui sont non toxiques et parmi
celles-là on a redécouvert que l'azé.t
qui était le premier médicament qu'on
donnait dans le sida avec ta
merveilleuse antibiotique contre Richard
au lit ce que tout le monde avait oublié
et que personne ne veut va
recommertialiser ça rapporte rien donc
c'est si vous voulez il y a il y a on se
heurte là si on fait passer une idée de
cette nature là j'ai pas vu vous rendez
compte des enjeux financiers monstrueux
mais pour tout le monde pour l'industrie
pour les journaux scientifiques
aux gens qui se dit dire ah oui il a la
grosse tête ou leur dites quoi
une taille de chapeau régulière
en nous je l'ai jamais vu ici parce que
ça se passe très bien avec nous mais il
y en a ceux qui disent ça qui c'est quoi
c'est une manière de vous attaquer c'est
quoi
j'en sais rien faut leur demander à eux
ce qu'ils entendent
c'est quoi votre relation avec Emmanuel
Macron maintenant on a beaucoup parlé
d'autres relations avec le président de
la République un coup vous étiez fâché
un coup il vous consultez tous les jours
un coup vous dormiez chez lui un coup il
dormait dans un lit superposé ok c'est
quoi la
[Musique]
si vous voulez je peux pas dire que j'ai
été convaincu par le l'enthousiasme de
la vaccination généralisée dont je pense
qu'elle n'était pas on a voulu pour ça
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
je vous rappelais ce que je disais j'ai
attend défaut prudemment là parce que il
y avait au moins trois raisons qui
laissait penser que
ça ne marcherait pas comment on
prédisait que ça marcherait c'est que il
y a aucun vaccin qui marche pour les
infections virales respiratoire 0,6 ça
marchait on aurait pu de grippe depuis
longtemps donc si ça marche pas pour la
grippe tous les ans c'est parce qu'il y
a un problème d'accord deuxièmement moi
j'ai su un peu plus tôt que les autres
que ce virus mutait très très rapidement
ce qui était l'inverse de ce qu'on
pensait sur les coronavirus US pour des
raisons techniques sur lequel je veux
pas m'étendre mais la véritable pandémie
a commencé en Italie parce qu'il y a eu
deux mutations qui sont passées une
mutation dans la machine à reproduire le
virus qui a fait qui fait 100 fois plus
d'erreurs que tous les autres
coronavirus et c'est 100 fois plus
d'erreurs c'est ce qui explique tous ces
variants donc là tous ceux qui vont
faire le rappel du vaccin pour pour vous
c'est inutile
je sais pas si c'est utile toute manière
tous les vaccins pour tous les vaccins
il est question de et pour toutes les
actions médicales que l'on a pour les
patients c'est de faire la balance entre
le bénéfice et le risque si vous n'avez
aucun risque si vous voulez vous n'avez
aucun bénéfice à espérer donc il y a une
étude indépendamment d'un autre on
trouve la même chose des Suédois très
complètes très carré comme les
Scandinaves sur 10000 personnes de moins
de 45 ans qui font la maladie il y a un
mort d'accord donc et pendant la période
d'observation il y avait 10% de gens qui
ont la maladie donc ce qui veut dire que
chez les moins de 45 ans il y avait un
mort sur 100000 donc vous pouvez pas
évaluer un vaccin permettant de montrer
qu'il y a moins d'un mort sur 100 000
c'est pas possible il faudrait que vous
en testiez un million avant donc mais en
revanche comme la moitié des gens qui
sont morts en plus de 85 ans si vous
vaccinez les jambes plus de 85 ans vous
faites pas quelque chose de fou quand
même vous faites quelque chose et nous
on voit qu'effectivement chez les gens
sont très arrivent excellente plus 75
ans toujours dans notre série de 30000
personnes le vaccin a un effet
protecteur chez Jean de plus de 75 ans
de de de des deux tiers il y a deux fois
il y a un tiers de gens qui vont faire
des formes mortelles
il est pas il est pas positif quoi voilà
il est pas il a surtout on sait que nous
on a su ça très tôt on sait que il peut
y avoir des porteurs sains dans le même
nombre dans le même pourcentage et les
vacciné et non vaccinés pourquoi
professeur à vous on avait l'impression
que le coït c'était la fin du monde il y
a deux trois trois ans et que maintenant
plus personne n'en parle pourquoi
si vous voulez la fin du monde était
toujours là le covid à la fin du monde
était programmée donc si vous voulez ça
fait je m'excuse c'est une marque de
l'âge mais j'ai écrit il y a 20 ans
exactement un rapport pour le ministère
de la Santé pour dire et on en a assez
des crises en maladie infectieuses qui
surviennent tous les deux ans qui
mettent la panique et on ne on met pas
en place les outils pour permettre d'y
faire face ce que j'ai essayé de faire
avec les hachu et il y a un affolement
répété qu'à l'époque j'avais été
sollicitée vous rappeler pour l'histoire
du bio théorie qui était une énorme
fantaisie c'était une manipulation
affreuse des États-Unis pour attaquer
miracle et j'en ai gardé un souvenir
absolument affreux parce que on s'est
fait intoxiqué moi je recevais de la
formation grise qui disait ça y est on a
trouvé en Irak quand j'étais au
ministère on a trouvé on sait que c'est
sorti ont été les fortes des trick les
les souches qui ont été utilisées aux
États-Unis on les a analysé le génome et
le génome celui de la bactérie qui avait
été militarisée par les Américains à
forte d'éthique et ils ont quand même il
y en avait quand même y remué ça à l'ONU
en disant regardez avec cette poudre là
vous rendez compte ils nous mettent des
tonnes de cette poudre donc le bio
terrorisme ça a été pareil un fantôme
qui a coûté des milliards est-ce que ça
a jamais marché ça marche pas est-ce que
tu diras où des tests les journalistes
oh non non je teste personne
c'est pas mon truc et puis je pense
c'est pas les journalistes les
journalistes sont pas sont pas des
extraterrestres ils sont ils émanent de
la population ordinaire donc c'est un
sous-ensemble stupide et les
journalistes ignorants ou les traités de
stupides et d'ignorance
mais vous dites un truc que j'aime bien
et rares émissions auxquelles j'ai
participé sont d'abord celles de Cyril
Hanouna bravo professeur d'une certaine
bienveillance est un son journalistique
plus affirmé que nombre de ses confrères
moi je suis pas journaliste mais bon
c'est pas mes confrères déjà en pensant
des questions non pas pour qui que ce
soit vous pouvez essayer par tous les
moyens de démontrer au moins d'affirmer
que ce que je disais forcément des
bêtises mais pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se jouait merci à vous en tout
cas de m'avoir cité dans le livre merci
non mais là qui était reçu par le
professeur c'est que il m'a appelé pour
me dire que le sketch de la
chauve-souris était typiquement exemple
type de comment déclencher la panique
sur un maximum de gens et j'étais très
flatté exactement
je voudrais juste reprendre une image
oui ce journaliste c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas que les journées c'est un il y
a un ensemble si vous voulez qui est que
finalement tout ça des filtres très vite
et on veut avoir juste quelques mots
simples qui permettent soi-disant de
comprendre et qui perdent pas du tout
comprendre parce que la plupart des
choses quand on les investissent sont
sont complexes et donc je pense qu'on
vit dans un monde un peu jeune pour
avoir connu ça mais c'est mon âge on vit
dans un monde de Shadoks oui vous voyez
ce que c'était les Shadoks non mais
Shadoks c'était les petits animaux c'est
un dessin animé vous voyez il n'y avait
que quatre cases dans la tête vous voyez
qui était gabusé et donc pour pouvoir
leur faire rentrer quelque chose il
fallait enlever une case pour pouvoir le
remontrer donc on vit dans un monde de
Shadoks on vit dans un monde dans lequel
on peut dire que des choses très simples
quand vous parlez du vaccin c'est on est
pour ou contre les vaccins vous parlez
de donc
c'est même pas venu en ces choses sont
plus complexes mais on est des choses
avec des essuies glaces c'est-à-dire que
on dit une bêtise et le lendemain on en
dit une autre et on a oublié la bêtise
qu'on avait dit la veille et donc ça
c'est le monde ça reconnait les branches
c'est le monde des journalistes c'est à
dire c'est la vérité du jour pas
journaliste c'est la vérité du jour moi
je je connais j'ai une idée de
journaliste parce que j'ai dirigé une
école de journalisme d'accord ça fait
partie des choses que j'ai faites j'ai
restructuré l'école journaliste de
Marseille qui faisait partie du
périmètre de mon université et donc ces
journalistes qui m'ont expliqué ça quand
je leur disais mais pourquoi vous faites
pas de l'enseignement il m'a dit vous
l'enseignement c'est vous nous on vend
des journaux si je vends pas de journaux
je mange plus et donc si l'OM passe
c'était à Marseille donc dans le
provençal à l'époque si l'OM gagne on
vend 30% le journaux de plus c'est ça
notre métier et après
c'est très bien présumé ça vous gêne pas
vous allez dire un truc c'est une bêtise
demain après vous dites le contraire il
dit non mais pas du tout change vous
avez pas raisonnable journaliste
quotidien c'est à dire c'est la vérité
du jour c'est ça demain il y aurait une
autre vérité et donc c'est vrai que moi
mon monde c'est exactement l'opposé de
ça moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ça c'est
ce que je dis sera encore fait dans 30
regardez j'ai écrit je passe mon temps à
dire j'ai écrit un rapport de 450 pages
et à 20 ans vous pouvez le lire j'ai pas
honte c'est
toujours de d'actualité non mais c'est
vrai merci professeur Raoul Didier Raoul
autobiographie dit énormément de choses
la font très fort c'est à
l'autobiographie de dire à ou merci
d'avoir été avec nous arrêter de me dire
ah oui il vient de raconter